mois déjà ça fait trois ans que c'est
terminé moi j'ai payé mon dû j'ai fait
de la prison pour ça j'ai fait 28 jours
mais pourquoi on me ressort toujours
prêt à vous avez fait de la prison d'ain
semble c'était pour la drogue a
tâtonné avant de parler c'était pas dans
un tournage c'était à l'extérieur à
amsterdam ce qu'est vraiment rien à voir
aux sommations oui d'accord voilà
d'accord et qu'il avait pris 28 jours de
prison oui parce que en fait tout le
monde a cru que c'était moins le
trafiquant d'armes c'est pour ça qu'ils
ont regardé en gros ben voilà alors
juste vingt ans après et doit
aujourd'hui terminée tout ça oui il m'a
regardé je suis veltman enfin à la
drogue
alors
je t'explique moi tu veux ça fait trois
ans qu'on ne parle de ça vincent shogun
voilà mais ça c'était le passé
maintenant c'est le présent non mesdames
et chansons sans carte juste juste nommé
juste ma paie rien de façon importante
je me suis dis parce que moi elle a
plein de deux jeunes qui nous regardent
souvent un exemple pour plein de choses
moi je te regarde souvent c'est gentil
alors illettré il est très drôle
et vincent juste important de dire tu te
sens mieux maintenant je me sens
vraiment mieux pas franchement je me
sens bien maintenant parce que c'est
vrai qu'avant j'étais très stressée que
c'est à d'autres domaines est en
confiance je connais quoi la cocaïne
cocaïne c est ça te faisais oui mais ça
te faisais quoi non mais attends il a
droit non mais attends attends d autres
si la droite veut dire dr toi là on est
en train car de très franc de très peu
la bien sûr je dis la vérité parce que
amener ça fait trois ans tout me dit
vincent shogunat sans shogun là c'est
trop moi j'ai payé mon dieu j'ai assumé
devant tout le monde oui j'ai fait j'ai
consommé parce que pourquoi j'étais pas
bien et que c'était pour des raisons
qu'elle sonnait vrai qu'est-ce que cette
faisait la cocaïne j'étais à prêt pour
ce n'était pas forcément dans le bon
sens mais en basque en fait j'ai perdu
mon père d'accord donc c'était déjà très
dur donc malheureusement avec ça c'était
pas forcément bon donc c'est vraiment du
brun ça tu vois mais ça je le savais
mais vu j'étais très mal entouré à
l'époque parce que avant c'était pas
comme maintenant parce qu'avant c'était
tout ce qui est booking et tout ce qui
est soir et donc forcément qui dit
soirée qui dit soirée drogue ça c'était
moi ça c'était mon passé maintenant
aujourd'hui on est vraiment bien cadrée
alors vous faites quoi aujourd'hui je
suis un peu influenceurs d'accord vous
faites plus de télé réalité pour
l'instant c'est compliqué parce que en
fait j'ai le blaze de la drogue mais moi
j'ai fait mon du jaf et 28 jours et je
suis aujourd'hui vous vous êtes celui
qui avait pris pour tout le monde sait
ça dans le monde donc après à mes
baskets donc idiot la rigole mais moi je
suis l'algérie en tant que tranquille
shogunat avec heroes et surtout de
tonnac voilà non mais voilà mes chiens
mais juste vincent voilà pourquoi quand
vous dites vous avez pris pour tout le
monde c'est à dire que les autres aussi
se droguer c'est vous qui avez tout prix
non c'est pas que les autres ont pris
c'est que moi j'ai dit la vérité moi
j'ai pris j'ai assumé et voilà sk de la
drogue la télé réalité alors déjà n'y a
pas de drogue dans la télévision moi
j'en prenais avec moi peut-être pas pour
les pas sur les tournages on m'a pas
aidé non en gros j'ai fait dix ans de
tournage en gros 10 ans je fais tout
l'an dernier jouera pas tant que ça à
mes chers je ne sais pas la production
qui donnait ce produit à mon avis faut
arrêter de dire voilà un sujet qu'il a
fait la différence dans la production de
riz est ce que tu es dans la production
ou pas ou non vous avez fait les gens je
connais bien j'ai fait les anges c'est
pas parce que moi j'ai fait les enjeux
l'échiquier jeter ensuite à marseille et
ensuite le village étouffé donc je sais
quoi oui en skaï d'ailleurs personne
parce que moi et moi je parle jamais moi
j'ai assumé ou non mais tu vois moi j'ai
vraiment répond oui répond c'est que
c'est quoi votre problème alors non mais
j'ai pas de problème ils vont m'accuser
d'avoir houinato l'ère du buzz sur
smerwick trois enfants sont présents sa
part de d'estimer que j'ai envie de
faire du buzz sur son dos mais on était
dans une conversation avec magali où on
parlait effectivement de drogue en télé
réalité ce qui est quand même un fait et
n'est plus un secret c'est un secret de
polichinelle
j'ai pris cet exemple de vincent qui
effectivement reconnaît aujourd'hui
qu'il a quand même pris de la drogue je
ne vois même pas pourquoi tu as fait ce
vous avez pas excuse moi je te dis alors
et en cette vidéo franchement tu m'as
lubis mois d'armée pour faire du buzz
sur toi mais finalement c'est toi qui
fait le buzz non parce que sans je
tenais juste des exemples était très
factuelle en fait l'exemple c'est tout
enfin voilà donne en vrai que l'exemple
c'est un endroit dia ba oui en fait
l'exemple c'est que ça fait trois ans
que j'ai jamais rien dit donc là je dis
merci cyril de la main mais c'est
important parce que moi je fais 3 jean
louis blériot xi et à en donner alors
qualité voilà et je voudrais dire tu as
été relaxé j'aimerais bien après salon
flamand mais c'est écrit dans la pièce
donc je parle pas flamand a annoncé
leurs noms annoncés on sait je te lis je
dis merci
la justice du belge vincent non le drive
à pied passant vincent le truc quand on
vous disait et qu'on disait avec myriam
c'est que il ya énormément de gens qui
disent que dans et au vu des images dans
les émissions de télé réalité il ya
énormément de drogue qui circule dont de
la cocaïne voilà une
guilde vincent ce que je pense qu'il
faut pas s'en prendre aux candidats pour
moi les fautifs c'est des sociétés de
production qui clairement ferme les yeux
là-dessus pour deux raisons déjà parce
que quand les candidats sont alcoolisé
et drogué on va pas se mentir ils font
de meilleures séquences ils donnent plus
en tournage et deuxièmement parce qu'ils
sont dépassés par les événements et il
ya des tournages ou c'est les candidats
qui font la loi les candidats stars font
la paire allemands s'étaient valu à
l'époque moi je me rappelle avant
c'était il ya six sept ans c'était plus
flex maintenant je pense que c'est plus
sécurisé je pense parce que moi ça fait
un petit moment que j'ai pas tourné
comme la vue de la drogue que peut
circuler dans la dans les camps
sahraouis
athènes attend attend mérite mais il a
dit
santos silva dire de très ouvert et
settat on discute on est ici pour parler
il ya aucun souci mais à aucun moment la
production l'a vu moi je me cachais
parce que pourquoi c'était une
dépendance parce que mon père est parti
au ciel je le répète encore une fois
voilà donc j'étais triste et ça me
permettait d'être en confiance et je le
dis ouvertement
voilà c'est tout l'art d'aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas la télé réalité qui a fait que
vincent prenais de la drogue et bien son
entourage c'est pour ce mauvais à
l'extérieur on ne peut pas dire que ce
soir la téléralité exactement a pris
meriam tu disait toi que voilà c'était
c'est tout c'est à nos messieurs
confirmé info les candidats pendant les
jours off vont se ravitailler dans les
différents pays en plus souvent des pays
où il ya facilement accès à des produits
à des stupéfiants donc oui je confirme
mes infos et je veux dire c'est pas un
secret de polichinelle on sait par
exemple de une personne comme comme
loana qui a avoué s'être drogué qui se
droguait pendant pendant pendant les
journées à fond on a des candidats je
vais pas citer non mais y ait des
candidats qui ont fait pipi dans leur
lit parce qu'elle était tellement
cocaïne et que voilà elle se rendait
même pas compter qu'on fini aux urgences
c'est des choses voilà qui se sont
passées alors peut-être que toi tu n'as
pas été tu n'y a pas eu la complicité de
la production est ce que là que la
production ne sais quel la drogue mais
bien sûr il ya des caméras partout comme
en valais c'est ça que cacher son rhume
voilà je me cachais réellement je me
cachais pour faire ça donc peut-être
qu'ils savent d'après ma phobie un
cachet sa fille oui elles le savent et
pire encore je ça les arrange presque
parce que la télé réalité c'est quand
même sens critique et un cd problème que
des gens regarde moi j'adore les mecs de
terrain mais c'est très dur mais c'est
vrai oui mais les mecs que j'adore me
sens où j'ai rencontré ces dessins sont
superbes et en vrai pour un producteur
c'est très dur de faire une télé réalité
parce que vous devez faire une heure par
jour avec du rien ça vous avez des gens
dans une maison qu'ils font un avion on
fait bien trois heures à la crise et
on va pas se mentir quand ils sont dans
un état second qui sont alcoolisés qui
sont drogués c'est horrible à dire mais
malheureusement ça les arrange parce que
ça donne des bonnes séquences et là où
ils sont intraitables sur la violence
par exemple dès qu'un candidat qui lève
la main sur l'autre encore plus sur une
femme il sort immédiatement de l'
aventure sur la drogue ils savent très
bien quelle robe qui l'on voit circuit
dans soirée mais ils ferment les yeux
mais c'est dur ce que tu dis est ce que
tu as quand même bossé pendant des
années un grosse équipe qui produit les
anges je cite pas de produit brut hors
tabac c'est que pour eux mais non
tu as fait quoi d'autre effet que pour
eux mais je pige pas là pour balancer
juste en bas voilà enfin juste à dire
aux téléspectateurs on aura des
nouvelles de benjamin castaldi au
courant
[Applaudissements]
ces nouvelles avant 21h très
certainement oui gilles verdez
malheureusement pour moi un sens il ya
une de vos déclarations qu'a retenu mon
attention j'aimerais bien avoir des
précisions vous avez dit je les
personnes ont fait pire que moi elles
font encore de la télé ça clairement
c'est de la télé réalité
donc ça sous-entend à mon avis quand
même que la consommation de drogue est
répandu dans les télé réalités la salle
presque un aveu de votre part parce que
en gros bas en fait pire commode dans le
sens que moi j'ai assumé vraiment bah
moi ce que je faisais que y'en a qui
l'ont caché et n'a pas été vue moi j'ai
assumé des départs oui c'est moi et
voilà basta chao dans quelle émission
par exemple dans les hanches mais le
gros droiture alors que tu parles avant
moi bonjour comment ça va
je voudrais pas me mettre à bas
donc je disais que en gros ses gardes
déjà tu t'es tu en est pas là
mais pas du tout parce que ça fait c'est
tout le temps on me le reproche vincent
non c'est ça c'est lourd à force de dire
maintenant c'est lourd donc on disait
oui dans quelle émission donc je crois
que ma dernière que j'ai fait c'était la
villa et vu j'étais pas vraiment bien
bien je crois que j'en avais trouvés ou
plus mais dans la wilaya livrer non non
j'en avais trouvé est il et qui libanité
non mais pas
trouvé
mais quand je
suis à côté je joue je n'ai pas avoir
trouvé c'est dans le sens où on était
dépendant d'accord voilà est abandonnée
quand on a besoin de sa dose et quand on
est dépendant à quelque chose on fait
tout pour trouver donc il ya d'autres
candidats qui tendance non moi même y
aller il a les mains libres eux mêmes et
c'était le jour off quand voilà
simplement